OK.
Good.
The final class in linear
algebra at MIT this Fall
is to review the whole course.
And, you know the best
way I know how to review
is to take old exams and just
think through the problems.
So it will be a three-hour
exam next Thursday.
Nobody will be able to take an
exam before Thursday, anybody
who needs to take it
in some different way
after Thursday should
see me next Monday.
I'll be in my office Monday.
OK.
May I just read
out some problems
and, let me bring the board
down, and let's start.
OK.
Here's a question.
This is about a 3-by-n matrix.
And we're given --
so we're given --
given -- A x equals 1
0 0 has no solution.
And we're also given A x equals
0 1 0 has exactly one solution.
OK.
So you can probably
anticipate my first question,
what can you tell me about m?
It's an m-by-n matrix
of rank r, as always,
what can you tell me
about those three numbers?
So what can you tell me about
m, the number of rows, n,
the number of columns,
and r, the rank?
OK.
See, do you want to
tell me first what m is?
How many rows in this matrix?
Must be three, right?
We can't tell what n
is, but we can certainly
tell that m is three.
OK.
And, what do these
things tell us?
Let's take them one at a time.
When I discover that some
equation has no solution,
that there's some right-hand
side with no answer,
what does that tell me about
the rank of the matrix?
It's smaller m.
Is that right?
If there is no
solution, that tells me
that some rows of the matrix
are combinations of other rows.
Because if I had a
pivot in every row,
then I would certainly be
able to solve the system.
I would have particular
solutions and all the good
So any time that there's a
system with no solutions,
stuff. that tells me
that r must be below m.
What about the fact that if,
when there is a solution,
there's only one?
What does that tell me?
Well, normally there
would be one solution,
and then we could add in
anything in the null space.
So this is telling me the null
space only has the 0 vector in
it.
There's just one
solution, period,
so what does that tell me?
The null space has only
the zero vector in it?
What does that tell me about
the relation of r to n?
So this one solution
only, that means
the null space of the matrix
must be just the zero vector,
and what does that
tell me about r and n?
They're equal.
The columns are independent.
So I've got, now, r equals
n, and r less than m,
and now I also know m is three.
So those are really
the facts I know.
n=r and those numbers
are smaller than three.
Sorry, yes, yes.
r is smaller than m, and
n, of course, is also.
So I guess this summarizes
what we can tell.
In fact, why not
give me a matrix --
because I would often ask for
an example of such a matrix --
can you give me a matrix
A that's an example?
That shows this possibility?
Exactly, that
there's no solution
with that right-hand side, but
there's exactly one solution
with this right-hand side.
Anybody want to suggest
a matrix that does that?
Let's see.
What do I -- what vector do
I want in the column space?
I want zero, one, zero,
to be in the column space,
because I'm able
to solve for that.
So let's put zero, one,
zero in the column space.
Actually, I could
stop right there.
That would be a matrix with
m equal three, three rows,
and n and r are both one,
rank one, one column,
and, of course, there's
no solution to that one.
So that's perfectly
good as it is.
Or if you, kind of,
have a prejudice
against matrices that
only have one column,
I'll accept a second
column.
So what could I include
as a second column
that would just be a different
answer but equally good?
I could put this vector in the
column space, too, if I wanted.
That would now be a case
with r=n=2, but, of course,
three m eq- m is still
three, and this vector is not
in the column space.
So you're -- this is just like
prompting us to remember all
those things, column space,
null space, all that stuff.
Now, I probably asked
a second question
about this type of thing.
OK.
Oh, I even asked, write
down an example of a
Ah. matrix that fits
the description.
Hm.
I guess I haven't learned
anything in twenty-six years.
CK.
Cross out all statements that
are false about any matrix with
these -- so again, these are
-- this is the preliminary sta-
these are the facts about my
matrix, this is one example.
But, of course, by
having an example,
it will be easy to check some
of these facts, or non-facts.
Let me, let me write
down some, facts.
Some possible facts.
So this is really true or false.
The determinant --
this is part one,
the determinant of A transpose
A is the same as the determinant
of A A transpose.
Is that true or not?
Second one, A transpose
A, is invertible.
Is invertible.
Third possible fact, A A
transpose is positive definite.
So you see how, on
an exam question,
I try to connect the
different parts of the course.
So, well, I mean,
the simplest way
would be to try it with that
matrix as a good example,
but maybe we can
answer, even directly.
Let me take number two first.
Because I'm -- you know, I'm
very, very fond of that matrix,
A transpose A.
And when is it invertible?
When is the matrix A
transpose A, invertible?
The great thing is that I
can tell from the rank of A
that I don't have to
multiply out A transpose A.
A transpose A, is invertible --
well, if A has a null space
other than the zero vector,
then it -- it's -- no way
it's going to be invertible.
But the beauty is, if the null
space of A is just the zero
vector, so the fact
-- the key fact is,
this is invertible if
r=n, by which I mean,
independent columns of A.
In A.
In the matrix A.
If r=n -- if the matrix A
has independent columns,
then this combination,
A transpose A,
is square and still
that same null space,
only the zero vector,
independent columns all good,
and so, what's the true/false?
Is it -- is this middle one T
or F for this, in this setup?
Well, we discovered that --
we discovered that -- that r
was n, from that second fact.
So this is a true.
That's a true.
And, of course, A transpose
A, in this example,
would probably be -- what
would A transpose A, be,
for that matrix?
Can you multiply A
transpose A, and see what
it looks like for that matrix?
What shape would it be?
It will be two by two.
And what matrix will it be?
The identity.
So, it checks out.
OK, what about A A transpose?
Well, depending
on the shape of A,
it could be good or not so good.
It's always symmetric,
it's always square,
but what's the size, now?
This is three by n,
and this is n by three,
so the result is three by three.
Is it positive definite?
I don't think so.
False.
If I multiply that by A
transpose, A A transpose,
what would the rank be?
It would be the same as
the rank of A, that's --
it would be just rank two.
And if it's three-by-three,
and it's only rank two,
it's certainly not
positive definite.
So what could I say
about A A transpose,
if I wanted to, like, say
something true about it?
It's true that it is
positive semi-definite.
If I made this semi-definite,
it would always be true, always.
But if I'm looking
for positive definite,
then I'm looking at the null
space of whatever's here,
and, in this case,
it's got a null space.
So A, A -- eh, shall
we just figure it out,
here?
A A transpose, for that
matrix, will be three-by-three.
If I multiplied
A by A transpose,
what would the first row be?
All zeroes, right?
First row of A A
transpose, could only
be all zeroes, so it's probably
a one there and a one there,
or something like that.
But, I don't even
know if that's right.
But it's all zeroes
there, so it's certainly
not positive definite.
Let me not put anything up
I'm not sh- don't check.
What about this determinant?
Oh, well, I guess --
that's a sort of
tricky question.
Is it true or
false in this case?
It's false, apparently, because
A transpose A, is invertible,
we just got a true for this
one, and we got a false,
we got a z- we got
a non-invertible one
for this one.
So actually, this one
is false, number one.
That surprises us,
actually, because it's,
I mean, why was it tricky?
Because what is true
about determinants?
This would be true if
those matrices were square.
If I have two square matrices,
A and any other matrix B,
could be A transpose, could
be somebody else's matrix.
Then it would be true that
the determinant of B A
would equal the
determinant of A B.
But if the matrices are not
square and it would actually be
true that it would be equal
-- that this would equal
the determinant of A times the
determinant of A transpose.
We could even split up those
two separate determinants.
And, of course,
those would be equal.
But only when A is square.
So that's just, that's a
question that rests on the,
the falseness rests on the
fact that the matrix isn't
square in the first place.
OK, good.
Let's see.
Oh, now, even asks more.
Prove that A transpose
y equals c --
hah-God, it's -- this
question goes on and on.
now I ask you about
A transpose y=c.
So I'm asking you
about the equation --
about the matrix A transpose.
And I want you to prove that
it has at least one solution --
one solution for every c,
every right-hand side c,
and, in fact -- in fact,
infinitely many solutions
for every c.
OK.
Well, none -- none
of this is difficult,
but, it's been a little while.
So we just have to think again.
When I have a system of
equations -- this is --
this matrix A transpose is now,
instead of being three by n,
it's n by three, it's n by m.
Of course.
To show that a system has
at least one solution,
when does this, when
does this system --
when is the system
always solvable?
When it has full row rank,
when the rows are independent.
Here, we have n rows,
and that's the rank.
So at least one solution,
because the number
of rows, which is n,
for the transpose,
is equal to r, the rank.
This A transpose
had independent rows
because A had independent
columns, right?
The original A had independent
columns, when we transpose it,
it has independent rows, so
there's at least one solution.
But now, how do I even know
that there are infinitely
many solutions?
Oh, what do I --
I want to know something
about the null space.
What's the dimension of the
null space of A transpose?
So the answer has got
to be the dimension
of the null space of
A transpose, what's
the general fact?
If A is an m by n
matrix of rank r,
what's the dimension
of A transpose?
The null space of A transpose?
Do you remember that
little fourth subspace
that's tagging along
down in our big picture?
It's dimension was m-r.
And, that's bigger than zero.
m is bigger than r.
So there's a lot
in that null space.
So there's always one
solution because n i- this
is speaking about A transpose.
So for A transpose, the roles
of m and n are reversed,
of course, so I'm --
keep in mind that this
board was about A transpose,
so the roles -- so it's the
null space of a transpose,
and there are m-r
free variables.
OK, that's, like,
just some, review.
Can I take another problem
that's also sort of --
suppose the matrix A has
three columns, v1, v2, v3.
Those are the columns
of the matrix.
All right.
Question A.
Solve Ax=v1-v2+v3.
Tell me what x is.
Well, there, you're
seeing the most --
the one absolutely
essential fact about matrix
multiplication,
how does it work,
when we do it a column at a
time, the very, very first day,
way back in September, we
did multiplication a column
at a time.
So what's x?
Just tell me?
One minus one, one.
Thanks.
OK.
Everybody's got that.
OK?
Then the next question is,
suppose that combination is
zero --
oh, yes, OK, so
question (b) says --
part (b) says, suppose
this thing is zero.
Suppose that's zero.
Then the solution is not unique.
Suppose I want true or false.
-- and a reason.
Suppose this
combination is zero.
v1-v2+v3.
Show that -- what
does that tell me?
So it's a separate
question, maybe
I sort of saved time
by writing it that way,
but it's a totally
separate question.
If I have a matrix, and I know
that column one minus column
two plus column
three is zero, what
does that tell me about whether
the solution is unique or not?
Is there more than one solution?
What's uniqueness about?
Uniqueness is about,
is there anything
in the null space, right?
The solution is
unique when there's
nobody in the null space
except the zero vector.
And, if that's zero, then this
guy would be in the null space.
So if this were zero, then this
x is in the null space of A.
So solutions are never
unique, because I could always
add that to any solution,
and Ax wouldn't change.
So it's always that question.
Is there somebody
in the null space?
OK.
Oh, now, here's a totally
different question.
Suppose those three vectors,
v1, v2, v3, are orthonormal.
So this isn't going to happen
for orthonormal vectors.
OK, so part (c),
forget part (b).
c.
If v1, v2, v3,
are orthonormal --
so that I would usually
have called them q1, q2, q3.
Now, what combination --
oh, here's a nice question,
if I say so myself --
what combination of v1
and v2 is closest to v3?
What point on the
plane of v1 and v2
is the closest point to v3 if
these vectors are orthonormal?
So let me --
I'll start the sentence -- then
the combination something times
v1 plus something times v2 is
the closest combination to v3?
And what's the answer?
What's the closest vector
on that plane to v3?
Zeroes.
Right.
We just imagine the x, y,
z axes, the v1, v2, th- v3
could be the standard
basis, the x, y, z vectors,
and, of course, the point on
the xy plane that's closest
to v3 on the z axis is zero.
So if we're orthonormal,
then the projection
of v3 onto that plane
is perpendicular,
it hits right at zero.
OK, so that's like a quick --
you know, an easy question,
but still brings it out.
OK.
Let me see what, shall I
write down a Markov matrix,
and I'll ask you
for its eigenvalues.
OK.
Here's a Markov matrix --
this -- and, tell
me its eigenvalues.
So here -- I'll
call the matrix A,
and I'll call this as point
two, point four, point four,
point four, point four, point
two, point four, point three,
point three, point four.
OK.
Let's see -- it helps out to
notice that column one plus
column two --
what's interesting about
column one plus column two?
It's twice as much
as column three.
So column one plus column two
equals two times column three.
I put that in there,
column one plus column two
equals twice column three.
That's observation.
OK.
Tell me the eigenvalues
of the matrix.
OK, tell me one eigenvalue?
Because the matrix is singular.
Tell me another eigenvalue?
One, because it's
a Markov matrix,
the columns add to
the all ones vector,
and that will be an
eigenvector of A transpose.
And tell me the
third eigenvalue?
Let's see, to make
the trace come out
right, which is point eight,
we need minus point two.
OK.
And now, suppose I start
the Markov process.
Suppose I start with u(0) --
so I'm going to look at the
powers of A applied to u(0).
This is uk.
And there's my matrix, and
I'm going to let u(0) be --
this is going to
be zero, ten, zero.
And my question is,
what does that approach?
If u(0) is equal to
this -- there is u(0).
Shall I write it in?
Maybe I'll just write in u(0).
A to the k, starting with
ten people in state two,
and every step follows
the Markov rule,
what does the solution
look like after k steps?
Let me just ask you that.
And then, what happens
as k goes to infinity?
This is a steady-state
question, right?
I'm looking for
the steady state.
Actually, the question doesn't
ask for the k step answer,
it just jumps right
away to infinity --
but how would I express
the solution after k steps?
It would be some multiple of
the first eigenvalue to the k-th
power -- times the
first eigenvector,
plus some other multiple
of the second eigenvalue,
times its eigenvector, and
some multiple of the third
eigenvalue, times
its eigenvector.
OK.
Good.
And these eigenvalues are
zero, one, and minus point two.
So what happens as
k goes to infinity?
The only thing that
survives the steady state --
so at u infinity, this
is gone, this is gone,
all that's left is c2x2.
So I'd better find x2.
I've got to find
that eigenvector
to complete the answer.
What's the eigenvector
that corresponds
to lambda equal one?
That's the key eigenvector
in any Markov process,
is that eigenvector.
Lambda equal one
is an eigenvalue,
I need its eigenvector
x2, and then
I need to know how much of it
is in the starting vector u0.
OK.
So, how do I find
that eigenvector?
I guess I subtract one
from the diagonal, right?
So I have minus point
eight, minus point eight,
minus point six, and the
rest, of course, is just --
still point four, point
four, point four, point four,
point three, point
three, and hopefully,
that's a singular matrix, so
I'm looking to solve A minus Ix
equal zero.
Let's see -- can anybody
spot the solution here?
I don't know, I didn't
make it easy for myself.
What do you think there?
Maybe those first two
entries might be --
oh, no, what do you think?
Anybody see it?
We could use elimination
if we were desperate.
Are we that desperate?
Anybody just call out if
you see the vector that's
in that null space.
Eh, there better be a
vector in that null space,
or I'm quitting.
Uh, ha- OK, well, I guess
we could use elimination.
I thought maybe somebody might
see it from further away.
Is there a chance
that these guys are --
could it be that these two are
equal and this is whatever it
takes, like, something
like three, three, two?
Would that possibly work?
I mean, that's great for this
-- no, it's not that great.
Three, three, four --
this is, deeper mathematics
you're watching now.
Three, three, four, is that --
it works!
Don't mess with it!
It works!
Uh, yes.
OK, it works, all right.
And, yes, OK, and, so that's
x2, three, three, four,
and, how much of that vector
is in the starting vector?
Well, we could go through
a complicated process.
But what's the beauty
of Markov things?
That the total number
of the total population,
the sum of these doesn't change.
That the total number of
people, they're moving around,
but they don't get born
or die or get dead.
So there's ten of them at the
start, so there's ten of them
there, so c2 is
actually one, yes.
So that would be the
correct solution.
OK.
That would be the u infinity.
So I used there,
in that process,
sort of, the main
facts about Markov
matrices to, to get
a jump on the answer.
OK. let's see.
OK, here's some, kind of
quick, short questions.
Uh, maybe I'll move over to
this board, and leave that for
the moment.
I'm looking for
two-by-two matrices.
And I'll read out the property
I want, and you give me
an example, or tell me
there isn't such a matrix.
All right.
Here we go.
First -- so two-by-twos.
First, I want the
projection onto the line
through A equals
four minus three.
So it's a one-dimensional
projection matrix
I'm looking for.
And what's the formula for it?
What's the formula for the
projection matrix P onto a line
through A. And then we'd just
plug in this particular A.
Do you remember that formula?
There's an A and an A
transpose, and normally we
would have an A transpose
A inverse in the middle,
but here we've just got numbers,
so we just divide by it.
And then plug in A
and we've got it.
So, equals.
OK.
You can put in the numbers.
Trivial, right.
OK.
Number two.
So this is a new problem.
The matrix with eigenvalue zero
and three and eigenvectors --
well, let me write these
down. eigenvalue zero,
eigenvector one, two, eigenvalue
three, eigenvector two, one.
I'm giving you the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
instead of asking for them.
Now I'm asking for the matrix.
What's the matrix, then?
What's A?
Here was a formula,
then we just put
in some numbers, what's
the formula here,
into which we'll just
put the given numbers?
It's the S lambda
S inverse, right?
So it's S, which is
this eigenvector matrix,
it's the lambda, which
is the eigenvalue matrix,
it's the S inverse, whatever
that turns out to be,
let me just leave it as inverse.
That has to be it, right?
Because if we went in
the other direction,
that matrix S would diagonalize
A to produce lambda.
So it's S lambda S inverse.
Good.
OK, ready for number three.
A real matrix that cannot
be factored into A --
I'm looking for a matrix
A that never could
equal B transpose B, for any B.
A two-by-two matrix that could
not be factored in the form B
transpose B.
So all you have to do is think,
well, what does B transpose B,
look like, and then pick
something different.
What do you suggest?
Let's see.
What shall we take for
a matrix that could not
have this form, B transpose B.
Well, what do we know
about B transpose B?
It's always symmetric.
So just give me any
non-symmetric matrix,
it couldn't possibly
have that form.
OK.
And let me ask the fourth
part of this question --
a matrix that has
orthogonal eigenvectors,
but it's not symmetric.
What matrices have
orthogonal eigenvectors,
but they're not
symmetric matrices?
What other families of matrices
have orthogonal eigenvectors?
We know symmetric matrices
do, but others, also.
So I'm looking for
orthogonal eigenvectors,
and, what do you suggest?
The matrix could
be skew-symmetric.
It could be an
orthogonal matrix.
It could be symmetric,
but that was too easy,
so I ruled that out.
It could be skew-symmetric
like one minus one, like that.
Or it could be an orthogonal
matrix like cosine sine,
minus sine, cosine.
All those matrices would
have complex orthogonal
eigenvectors.
But they would be orthogonal,
and so those examples are fine.
OK.
We can continue a little longer
if you would like to, with
these --
from this exam.
From these exams.
Least squares?
OK, here's a least
squares problem in which,
to make life quick,
I've given the answer --
it's like Jeopardy!, right?
I just give the answer,
and you give the question.
OK.
Whoops, sorry.
Let's see, can I stay over
here for the next question?
OK.
least squares.
So I'm giving you the problem,
one, one, one, zero, one, two,
c d equals three, four, one,
and that's b, of course,
this is Ax=b.
And the least
squares solution --
Maybe I put c hat
d hat to emphasize
it's not the true solution.
So the least square solution
-- the hats really go here --
is eleven-thirds and minus one.
Of course, you could have
figured that out in no time.
So this year, I'll ask
you to do it, probably.
But, suppose we're
given the answer,
then let's just
remember what happened.
OK, good question.
What's the projection P of
this vector onto the column
space of that matrix?
So I'll write that
question down, one.
What is P?
The projection.
The projection of b onto the
column space of A is what?
Hopefully, that's what the
least squares problem solved.
What is it?
This was the best solution, it's
eleven-thirds times column one,
plus -- or rather, minus
one times column two.
Right?
That's what least squares did.
It found the combination
of the columns that
was as close as possible to b.
That's what least
squares was doing.
It found the projection.
OK?
Secondly, draw the straight
line problem that corresponds to
this system.
So I guess that the straight
line fitting a straight line
problem, we kind of recognize.
So we recognize,
these are the heights,
and these are the points,
and so at zero, one, two,
the heights are three,
and at t equal to one,
the height is four,
one, two, three, four,
and at t equal to two,
the height is one.
So I'm trying to fit
the best straight line
through those points.
God.
I could fit a
triangle very well,
but, I don't even know which
way the best straight line goes.
Oh, I do know how it goes,
because there's the answer,yes.
It has a height eleven-thirds,
and it has slope minus one,
so it's something like that.
Great.
OK.
Now, finally -- and this
completes the course --
find a different vector
b, not all zeroes,
for which the least square
solution would be zero.
So I want you to
find a different B
so that the least square
solution changes to all zeroes.
So tell me what I'm
really looking for here.
I'm looking for a b where the
best combination of these two
columns is the zero combination.
So what kind of a
vector b I looking for?
I'm looking for
a vector b that's
orthogonal to those columns.
It's orthogonal
to those columns,
it's orthogonal to
the column space,
the best possible answer is
zero.
So a vector b that's orthogonal
to those columns -- let's see,
maybe one of those minus two
of those, and one of those?
That would be orthogonal
to those columns,
and the best vector
would be zero, zero.
OK.
So that's as many questions
as I can do in an hour,
but you get three hours,
and, let me just say,
as I've said by e-mail, thanks
very much for your patience
as this series of
lectures was videotaped,
and, thanks for filling
out these forms,
maybe just leave them on the
table up there as you go out --
and above all, thanks
for taking the course.
Thank you.
Thanks.